and texas attorney general kim paxton
joins us now
ken why do you why do you want to push
back against these restrictions that the
mayor is imposing
well it's the mayor and the county judge
because they're in direct violation of
what the governor put out in his
executive order and his executive order
governs these restrictions he's already
restricted
bars and restaurants to either 75 or 50
occupancy but he said you cannot have
restrictions on time
and so they kind of tried to sneak this
in two days ago and
we're going to stop them because it's in
violation of state law
so dr mark scott is the austin health
authority from the austin health
authority this is why he says that these
restrictions
are necessary and backs up the the
austin mayor doing this if we take
individuals who are exposed during
christmas gatherings
and put them in bars on new year's eve
and pack them together for hours the
projection is going to be
overwhelming and happen very quickly
are you choosing to say that that's not
the case
ignore it or are you saying it's just
time to open businesses
what do you say back to the health
official who says that
no first of all my job is to enforce
whatever the law is these guys
are making up their own law they're not
allowed under texas law to do this so
they're just
operating sort of on their own outside
of texas law so my job isn't to decide
what the best policy is my job is to
enforce the law
i tend to believe that individuals
should be making their own decisions and
having curfews on restaurants is
probably not going to make much of a
difference
even though this particular doctor may
think so i don't see how it would affect
much of anything
interesting the texas governor abbott
says that this ban
is illegal as well this shutdown order
by austin is not allowed he says
period my executive order stops cities
like austin from arbitrarily shutting
down businesses
the city has a responsibility to enforce
existing orders
not make new ones he of course is
responding to the austin mayor who says
this can we have taken
limited action to help us arrest the
growth in cases
if we don't act now businesses are going
to suffer
even more families will suffer our way
of life will suffer
and it'll take us exponentially longer
to return to to life that is
normal i know that you have gone as far
as to suggest
that these leaders such as the mayor of
austin has contempt
for texans and the local businesses
there
no that i think he does and he doesn't
have the authority to do what he's doing
that's the problem here it would be like
anybody off the street saying i'm going
to make up a law for the rest of us to
follow he doesn't have the authority to
do that
when the governor has specifically set
out guidelines for the entire state
now if he wants to go through the
correct process and call the governor
and say hey i think we should change
this
and the governor decides to do that
that's how the process works not just
some local mayor
deciding to make up new rules for his
city giving putting curfews on
restaurants
how far do you plan to go with legal
action over these restrictions
so obviously they follow this you know
they they put this out on the 29th we
didn't know about till
yesterday we're having the act quickly
today we'll take it all the way to texas
supreme court if we have to so we're
we're on our we're on the path we think
in the end will be successful because
the law is pretty clear
ken as the attorney general of that
state i know you love texas
i know you love the people there how
badly has the economy
been hit as a result of these
restrictions
you know it's been tough and in certain
groups
restaurants hotels the travel industry
it's been devastating and it's
it's sad for me to see that because you
know people had no control over how it
affected their jobs
and at some point i think we're going to
have to get back to the decision-making
being at the individual level
based on people's own determinations
about what's best for their health and
their job and their situations
it's it's quite it's quite something to
watch as we wrap this year
2020 um you know just got done with the
segment where the doctor just got
vaccinated we hope more can get
vaccinated
ken great to talk to you thank you and
happy new year to you
happy new year from texas